you got a piece of toast you got eggs  and you got bacon and you're just eating  them one at a time put them all together  for a swift kick in the breakfast nuts  however for whatever reason a blt  refreshing  light i don't even like a turkey club  that much like i think the turkey club  ruins the blt concept because it adds  too much crap to it i don't know man i i  think i would i would i would venture to  say more people crave it  because it's an everyday type of food  than people crave a blt i'll go a step  further i find breakfast to be the most  useless meal on planet earth when  popular convention says it's the most  important well let popular convention  say whatever popular minch wants to say  i love that you had a cough like a 100  year old man are you out of your [ __ ]  sucking your mind